[Musique]
bakou
getty est une chose extraordinaire
[Musique]
mon grand père n'était pas seulement
l'homme le plus riche au monde
[Musique]
c'est l'homme le plus riche de
l'histoire du monde on vous ressemble
mais on n'est pas comme ça
c'est comme si on venait d'une autre
planète
où la force de la gravité est si
puissante qu'elle était vie la lumière
moi
et des voix les gens
le supplétif votre petit fils
la clé t on avant de lui c'est une
plaisanterie millions de dollars pour
les libérer
mais ce n'est pas d'argent demandez à
votre beauté à tout l'argent du monde
monsieur getty n'est pas disponible je
suis désolé madame getty
je travaille pour monsieur l'éthique
vous aidez retrouver votre fait ce ne
suis pas une vraie getty j'en ai
seulement est posée
je me parcourt trouve il faut payer la
rançon
ils font des choses à paul qui ne
s'arrangeront pas avec de l'argent
en tant que mère je vous implore de
libérer mon fils
il faut montrer qu'on est prêt à
renoncer je ne peux pas
[Musique]
monsieur getty combien êtes vous prêt à
payer pour récupérer votre petit fils si
ce n'est pas 10 7 millions de dollars
rien du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]